foreign
welcome to Simply learns YouTube channel
in this session we will learn how to
insert multiple rows in SQL table but
before we begin let me tell you guys
that we have daily updates on multiple
Technologies so if you're a tech gig in
a continuous hunt for latest
technological Trends then consider
getting subscribed to our YouTube
channel and don't forget to hit that
Bell icon to never miss an update from
Simply Iran now without further Ado
let's get started with our one point
agenda that is how to insert multiple
rows in SQL so let's quickly take a look
at the syntax that we will be using for
inserting multiple rows in a table using
SQL
now the syntax is as follows now here
you have the insert and into keywords
table name is the user defined name for
the table then you have the columns that
is column number one two and Etc then
after declaring the column names you
have the keyword values which will help
SQL understand this is a tuple and these
are the values involved inside the Tuple
that is Row 1 value 1 Row 1 value 2 so
on and Row 1 value n so this type of
syntax will help you to add one Tuple at
one time and this will take a lot of
time to process you can see to insert
the next apple we are writing a
completely new syntax once again using
the same insert into table name column
one two three and values and row number
two that is the second table right so
this type of code will take longer
duration to run as well as it will take
longer lines or number of lines will be
extra so is there a way where you can
add multiple tuples in one single curve
yes there is so the syntax will be
completely same right so you will be
using one insert into keyword one table
name and once you will be declaring all
the column numbers and once you will be
using the values keyword the only
difference is you will be adding
multiple tuples under the values bracket
right you will be declaring the number
of values you want to include in one
single go and this whole query becomes
as a whole and once you run this query
all the values will be added at once now
that you are clear with the syntax let's
quickly get back to the SQL workbench
and try to run this command
now we are on the MySQL workbench let's
quickly login
there you go we have logged in let's use
the simply learn database once again so
that we get access to the data which we
have so we already have an employee
stable
so let's see what's presently included
in employee stable select star
from employee
table semicolon
so this is the data that we already have
in our table now let's try to add some
more data
so now we will include one single
element or one single Tuple data related
to one single employee right using the
first type of syntax let's quickly
execute this
the command got executed again let's
quickly see what's present in the table
select start
from
employee table again you can see I'm
using lowercase for the user defined
keywords and uppercase for the
predefined keywords just to make sure
that the code is understandable
and which is the user defined keyword
and which is the predefined keyword so
these are the the ones in small case are
user defined and the ones in uppercase
are predefined right so we have
successfully included one single element
or one single Tuple the details which
are related to Prime and now let's try
to modify the same code and try to
include few more tuples inside the same
insert command and try to insert
multiple rows into the table
now here you can see we are using the
same insert into employee table command
and instead of Brian we replaced or we
added six more entries under the values
section right and the only difference is
we are trying to separate the tuples
using a comma you can see we are
enclosing one Tuple inside the
parenthesis and we are separating two
tuples with the help of a Karma right
ensure that you include comma between
every Tuple and you can ignore the comma
for the last up you can see we are not
using any sort of comma or any sort of
specifier at the end right so and we are
closing the command using the semicolon
this explains equal that it is the end
now we are going to run this command and
see the output
so there you go the command got
successfully executed now let's again
execute the select command and see if
the data is involved or included or
inserted into the given employee table
now there you go the command got
successfully executed and you can see
the table over here and you can see that
all the data or all the doubles we
included into the table using the insert
command in one go are successfully
included so that's how you insert
multiple rows into a table using SQL now
with that we have come to an end of this
session and if you have any queries
regarding any of the topics covered in
this session or if you require the
resources that we used in the session
like PPT code document Etc then do let
us know in the comment section below and
RT perfect we'll be more than happy to
resolve all your queries at the earliest
until next time thank you stay safe and
keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here